muy bien entonces lo que teníamos es que
partíamos de una función efe que
dependía de dos variables digamos x de
verdad y ésta en realidad es una función
escalar verdad toma valores escalares y
entonces la idea que hemos estado
desarrollando es tratar de aproximar
esta función alrededor de un punto dado
digamos x 0 10/0 verdad y hemos hablado
de lo que es la línea lización local de
nuestra función verdad n
en esencia tenemos aquí la fórmula de
cómo hacer la línea lización en
abstracto verdad en realidad parece como
una especie de bestia de fórmula pero
pero una vez que la desmenuzadas no es
tan aterradora y el objetivo de este
vídeo será tratar de extender esta idea
y literalmente será añadir términos a la
fórmula para hallar una aproximación que
ahora sea cuadrática esto es digamos
empezaremos a utilizar términos que
esencialmente tienen cosas como x
cuadrada
xy también pueden tener cosas como
cuadrada verdad que en esencia son
términos que tiene dos variables
multiplicándose verdad aquí es x x x x x
ye yé porque muy bien entonces si por
ejemplo tratamos ahora digamos en
principio de analizar nuestra función
que nos define la línea lización local
aquí podemos ver que tenemos un término
constante aquí tenemos un término
constante verdad que en esencia es nada
más un número verdad es sólo evaluar la
función en el punto que nos interesa acá
tenemos también otro número que es
evaluar la derivada parcial de f con
respecto de x en el punto que nos
interesaba y lo mismo ocurre de este
lado laden esencia estos son sólo 3
es verdad así que la única parte
variable es esta donde se encuentra xy
donde se encuentra allí y lo he escrito
de esta forma digamos abstracta para que
veas lo que hay que digamos enchufar
para cualquier función y para cualquier
punto de entrada y poder encontrar su
línea lización local alrededor de ese
punto verdad entonces vamos a borrar por
un momento esta parte de la digamos de
esta parte cuadrática verdad y ya que
hemos puesto la aproximación lineal
entonces vamos a repasar sus propiedades
y vamos a tratar o vamos a procurar que
el que la aproximación cuadrática
también tenga algunas de esas
propiedades muy bien entonces la primera
propiedad que podríamos tratar de ver es
qué pasa si evaluamos nuestra función l
en el punto x 0 10/0 bien vamos a tratar
de evaluar esta función en el punto x 0
y es 0 y si nos damos cuenta en realidad
pues por supuesto que tenemos f evaluada
en x0 y es 0 porque en realidad esto es
una constante verdad esto no depende ni
de x ni de ella así que
esto está fijo verdad pero si ahora
sustituimos con x0 en esta parte verdad
entonces este término se cancela y lo
mismo pasa de este lado al sustituir con
de cero verdad entonces estos términos
se cancelan porque estos son los
términos que sí tienen variables
involucradas muy bien entonces aquí
están la variable x y la variable y
estos términos se cancelan y simplemente
nos queda que la función l evaluada en
el punto alrededor del cual queremos
aproximar coincide con el valor de la
función en ese mismo punto y esto es un
hecho importante porque pues por
supuesto si estamos pensando en la
aproximación de una función pues es
bueno que coincidan al menos en digamos
con la función original en el punto de
interés verdad ahora bien qué pasaría si
nosotros queremos calcular la derivada
parcial de l con respecto de x muy bien
entonces si nosotros derivamos esta
expresión con respecto de x vemos que
como esto es constante
que esto vale 0 al derivar con respecto
de x y luego tenemos esta parte que es
una constante y que multiplica a x menos
x0 verdad entonces este término se
involucra a x y al derivar lo
simplemente nos quedamos con esta
constante verdad es muy fácil de ver eso
entonces vamos a tener efe la derivada
parcial de f con respecto de x evaluada
en el punto x 0 0 y al derivar esto con
respecto de x nos da 1 y por eso sólo
nos quedamos con esta constante y esto
que tenemos aquí sólo depende de verdad
todo esto depende sólo de ye así que en
realidad esto al derivar lo con respecto
de x nos da 0 verdad no tiene términos
correspondientes a x entonces nos
quedamos simplemente con esta este este
término verdad resulta que la derivada
parcial de l con respecto de x por
supuesto evaluada en el punto x 0 10/0
coincide con la derivada parcial
respecto de x de la función original en
ese punto verdad y ojo no significa que
coincida en todos lados sólo se da en
este punto x 0 0 verdad y lo mismo
ocurre con la derivada parcial de
nuestra función l con respecto de y
verdad esto simplemente será la derivada
de f con respecto de y evaluada en el
punto x 0 y es cero
en el punto x 0 0 verdad y ahora para
aproximar digamos con con términos
cuadráticas a la función entonces vamos
a copiar esta fórmula
y esta fórmula y vamos a pegarla y vamos
a pegarla más abajo muy bien
aquí tenemos nuestra función verdad y
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es agregarle
términos muy bien vamos a agregarle
términos cuadráticas verdad y por
supuesto esos términos deben ser tal que
coincidan con la información de las
segundas derivadas parciales verdad al
menos en el punto de interés así que en
lugar de l vamos a ponerle otro nombre
vamos a ponerle q porque esencialmente
va a ser otra función y esta función q
verdad será justamente el término
constante el término lineal o más bien
los términos lineales verdad y vamos a
agregar otros otros términos digamos a
equis cuadrada más b x x más c x
cuadrada ok entonces con esto ya estamos
agregando términos cuadrados y por
supuesto faltaría determinar quienes a
quienes ve y quién es el problema es que
esto se complica al evaluar en el punto
x 0 0 verdad porque por ejemplo si
evaluamos en x 0 y es cero
tenemos otro término constante que se
les sumaría al a
evaluada en el punto y esto ya no nos da
esta propiedad de que al evaluar en el
punto de interés coincida con evaluar la
función f en el punto verdad ya
tendríamos más términos entonces vamos a
borrar esta expresión y vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo que teníamos cuando
hablábamos de la línea lización local
verdad en lugar de poner x vamos a poner
x menos x 0 x menos x 0 y por supuesto
esto iba evaluado al cuadrado más otro
término b que multiplica a x menos x0
por el término correspondiente ayer
verdad que sería menos 10 0 muy bien de
menos 10 0 y finalmente sumamos otra
constante que multiplica a menos de 0
pero ahora esto va evaluado al cuadrado
muy bien entonces este sí lo vemos así
en realidad es una función enorme y
estas tres constantes todavía no las
hemos podido determinar verdad lo
haremos
tratando de que de que esta función cuba
próxima en lo más cercano a la función
original
efe ahora bien la parte importante de
poner digamos en los términos x menos x
0 o yemen o 70 es justamente para que al
evaluar en el punto x 0 y 0 es decir
poner x 0 aquí y espero acá verdad
entonces al evaluar ahí todo esto se va
a anular todos estos términos se van a
anular y sólo nos quedaría efe evaluada
en x 0 10/0 verdad eso eso era una
bonita propiedad de la línea lización
local que queremos que se extienda a la
cuadrática y lo mismo pasará con las
derivadas parciales aunque creo que eso
ya lo veremos mejor en otro vídeo así
que nos vemos luego